[Music]
vaca Trump is an assistant to the
president and her husband Jared Kushner
is a senior advisor to President Trump
they are also the parents of three small
children and lifelong New Yorkers so
this is a really big change for the
entire family she talked with us about
their new lifestyle when we met
yesterday at their new home in
Washington DC I actually I really loved
living in DC I really enjoy it here with
my children's but you're such a New
Yorker I'm such a neat well but that's
the great or never in my life would I
have thought that I would have actually
moved out of New York not while my
children were in school at least my
business was there my life was there so
this is actually an amazing moment in
time where I came to Washington and I
told Jared with with my kids say I want
to treat it almost like I'm I'm a
visitor every week I take my children to
a different museum or cultural
institution we went to the Supreme Court
we've been to five or six museums we
went to the monster truck show so so
just having real unique experience with
monster truck show yeah not exactly a
cultural experience yeah Joseph Mazda
show they don't have them nearby and in
New York as I've looked for years we
went in Baltimore but every week I try
to do something different and that's a
choice you can really celebrate being in
a different city and and in a different
community and it's been great I have a
backyard with a swing set as a New
Yorker yeah this doesn't happen yes so
it's a small backyard and my kids that
week into the hedge to have room for
them to clear but you at the monster
truck show surprises me as my son has
not stopped talking about it since he
talked about it for around three weeks
beforehand and ask him about monster
truck show he's actually sleeping right
now which is shocking that we made it
through this role without one of my my
two little boys that's it's a very nice
neighborhood you live in did you want to
live here because I saw Barack and
Michelle Obama's house around the corner
and Jeff and Mackenzie Bezos also live
in the neighborhood yes and Secretary
Tillerson lives here
and will burrows and so we have a nice
community yeah should voters get there
Ivanka 2024 campaign signs out near
speculation has already started
politics is a tough business started
tough business top of the one those New
Yorkers will appreciate this she said
she's never lived in a neighborhood nor
you know these Washington neighborhoods
well because you lived there too
so she said when they moved in she and
her daughter Arabella made cupcakes and
they went around and took them to the
neighbors which I thought was a really
nice thing to do as I'm sure she was
wondering how she would be received the
neighbors are very welcoming and very
inviting to her and Charlie the first
thing she asked me when I saw her guess
what what everybody says you get this -
how is Charlie I told her you were fine
and she was glad to hear that I very
much she's adjusting very I do too life
Indiana that's why I lived in a very
nice neighborhood
very very